bonjour donc on va parler de l'emprise
le thème l'emprise de conscience j'ai
beaucoup aimé l'idée de ce thème en
prise de conscience qui pour moi sont en
fait deux choses qui normalement ne vont
pas ensemble
en effet l'an prise de conscience et une
emprise sur votre conscience sur qui
vous êtes et le fait d'avoir conscience
qu'on est sous emprise et sont pour moi
deux choses dire être allemands opposés
donc la première chose évidemment est de
savoir comment sait-on que nous sommes
sous emprise
ce qui est vraiment le point le point
fondamental le point crucial le point le
plus important est de réussir à
déterminer et réussir à savoir si on est
sous emprise de problèmes qui se posent
quand on est sous emprise
c'est qu'évidemment on n'en a pas
conscience alors votre entourage va
peut-être être bienveillant ou vous-même
connaissez peut-être quelqu'un qui est
sous emprise et vous essayer à tout prix
de réveiller la personne de lui dire
voilà tu es sous emprise
il y a un problème que ce soit dans la
sphère professionnelle que ce soit dans
la sphère amoureuse l'extérieur on va
dire l'entourage est beaucoup plus
conscients de la problématique de la
personne qui vit le phénomène d'emprise
elle même c'est un mécanisme qui est
très particulier l'emprise parce que
c'est quelque chose en fait qui se met
en place au fil du temps c'est pas
quelque chose de brutal
c'est pas la même chose que vous tombez
dans l'escalier vous vous cassiez une
jambe bon voilà c'est évident la jambe
des casses et non le phénomène d'emprise
c'est quelque chose qui va vraiment
grandir et évoluer avec le temps la
personne qui veut sous son emprise va
tout faire pour détruire en fait qui
vous êtes là tout faire pour vous
empêcher de réfléchir vous empêcher
d'être vous même vous empêcher
de vivre tout simplement et d'être
heureux et épanoui
moi j'ai vécu sous emprise sous
l'emprise d'une personne pendant pendant
quelques années
et effectivement au début je ne
comprenais pas bien je ne comprenais pas
bien je pensais que c'était des petites
remarques des petites réflexions qui
allaient dans le bon sens et qui était
plus là pour pour me valoriser plutôt
que de me dévaloriser
je vous donne un exemple on se rend à un
dîner entre amis je mets une tenue et la
réflexion arrive
j'aime pas trop c'est rock show que ça
ne va pas je trouve qu'elle te met pas
en valeur je trouve qu'elle te fait des
grosses fesses je trouve qu'elle je sais
pas quelle qu'elle ne va pas la réaction
première est de se dire ah bon bah mince
ok on regarde se regarde dans le miroir
et d'un seul coup on a une perception de
la réalité qui devient différente à
travers les mots de l'autre on va
changer sa perception de la réalité
c'est à dire que comme l'autre nous a
dit que cette tenue ne nous mettait pas
en valeur
d'un seul coup la tenue que l'on
appréciait au départ ne nous mettra plus
en valeur et l'emprise c'est ça
l'emprise c'est des petites graines qui
vont être se met tout doucement au fil
du temps et qui vont monter crescendo
pour arriver à un niveau ou en fait vous
perdez votre identité vous perdez qu'il
vous êtes nés en même temps au fond de
vous il ya encore cette petite lumière
cette petite lueur qui fait que vous
savez pertinemment au plus profond de
vous vous savez pertinemment que tout ça
n'est pas la réalité mais cette réalité
est biaisé puisque au quotidien ya cette
petite dose qui est remise et qui
réinjecter et qui va vous remettre dans
la position d' erreur sur votre
perception de qui vous êtes
l'emprise je suis pas spécialiste
attention je suis quelqu'un qu'il l'a
vécue et qui a essayé d'en comprendre
les mets
kahnisme et d'emprise pour moi c'est
vraiment ça en tout cas dans la sphère
vraiment intime dans la sphère amoureuse
l'emprise c'est vraiment de ne plus se
voir comme on est réellement c'est la
perte de la confiance en soi c'est la
perte de son identité comme je l ai déjà
dit et c'est quelque chose qui vous est
un qui vous détruit et dans le même
temps on ne peut pas concevoir qu'on est
sous emprise
puisque normalement quelqu'un qui nous
aime n'est pas là pour vous détruire
donc c'est toute la complexité de la
chose qui fait qu'à un moment donné la
personne ait perdu alors oui il
entourage va vous dire d'inuk la façon
qu'il est de parler des fois pas génial
quand même
ouais mais bon keynes au quine ci ne se
dispute pas après tout lanvin couple qui
n'a pas deux heures qui n'a pas de
désaccord donc bon et on banalise
quelque part tout c'est tout c'est
toutes ces petites remarques toutes ces
réflexions qui ne devrait pas être
banalisés alors attention il faut pas
tomber dans l'excès de non plus ce n'est
pas parce que demain votre conjoint ou
conjointe va vous faire une réflexion ou
va vous faire une remarque que tout de
suite vous êtes dans une relation
toxique est dans une relation où il y à
un phénomène d'emprise
pas du tout longpré c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui est répétée au
quotidien du dénigrement du rabaissement
etc etc
alors comment on peut réussir à croire
toutes ces choses qui pourtant ne sont
pas réels au départ dans notre cerveau
qu'est ce qui se passe et qu'est ce qui
fait qu'à un moment donné on bascule et
on se dit 7 contre réalité devient ma
réalité on perd semble d'identité encore
une fois quand j'ai quitté cette
personne un jour j'étais en voiture avec
une amie et cet ami me dit non mais
quand même toit avec le caractère que tu
as le tempérament cta le franc-parler
que tu as
mais comment tu as fait pour courte
ce qui te disais comment tu as fait pour
imaginer que tu étais grosse que tu pues
est que toutes les autres étaient mieux
que toi etc etc
sur le coup je n'avais pas d'idée il y
avait rien qui m'était venu pour lui
expliquer comment effectivement basculer
dans l'emprise parce que ça demande un
travail après de comprendre ce qui a
fait qu'on a accepté parce qu'on accepte
en fait que ça existe et je me suis
retrouvé dans la voiture avec cet ami on
s'arrête au feu rouge et dans se coucher
pas une idée m'est venue et je les
regardais et j'ai regardé son ventre et
je lui dis mais dis donc tu aurais
appris du pourra bien évidemment mon ami
me répond non non pas du tout je n'ai
pas pris de poids et j'ai continué comme
ça et je vous invite vraiment à essayer
ça peut être pas une mauvaise mine ça
peut être plein de choses vous pouvez
essayer avec plein de choses
vous savez pertinemment que ce que vous
allez annoncer et fo mais vous y mettez
une force de persuasion et vous allez
voir ce qui se passe donc avec cet ami
au bout de sa pas duré longtemps
au bout de deux minutes j'ai réussi à
lui faire dire que oui peut être
effectivement elle avait pris du poids
simplement en lui disant et en lui
répétant mais comme ça de manière
sporadique peut-être trois quatre fois
dans la conversation
en posant mon regard sur les endroits
dont je lui parlais donc je vais parler
de son ventre après je vis d'imiter sûr
puisque là quand même
ce niveau là je trouve que je peine à
prix des joues non fâchez pas bizarre
dans mais peut-être je me trompe pas et
met le doute comme ça on sème le chaos
dans la pensée et ce qui s'est passé au
bout de deux minutes c'est que mon ami
m'a répondu tu sais maintenant que tu me
le dis je me suis pas pesé depuis un
moment mais c'est vrai que ce matin
quand j'ai pris mon jean
baj eu un peu de mal à le fermer j'ai
arrêté là j'ai dit à mon ami je t'arrête
tout de suite tu as pas du tout grossi
en tout cas je ne pense pas et je viens
juste de t'expliquer et de démons
très bas comment on peut tomber sous
emprise
ce que je veux dire par cet exemple
c'est que vous pouvez être n'importe qui
il faut arrêter de croire que des gens
qui tombent sous emprise sont des gens
faibles sont des gens fragiles sont des
gens je suis désolé je n'aime pas ce
thème mais sont des gens culturellement
ou intellectuellement inférieur c'est
faux n'importe qui peut tomber sous
l'emprise de notre personne comme ça du
jour au lendemain
d'autant plus quand il ya des sentiments
dans le monde professionnel c'est un peu
différent
l'emprise moi je je l'associé au burn
out en fait je pense que dans le travail
on n'est plus dans un dans une logique
de harcèlement effectivement si vous
avez un air plus sain ou un patron qui
vous harcèlent d'où le temps qui vous
met la pression constamment kivu
dévalorise c'est une forme d'emprise
bien sûr mais c'est une forme d'emprise
qui remet en doute vos compétences en
tant que professionnel dans votre
domaine et non pas en tant qu'individu
c'est là où il faut vraiment faire la
différence et bien et bien souvent
malheureusement les gens n'arrivent pas
à dissocier qui ils sont
professionnellement et qu'ils sont
personnellement il n'arrive pas à faire
la différence
et tout ça se mélange et à un moment
donné en fait ce qui se passe c'est que
on s'imagine que on n'est plus bon à
rien dans tous les domaines et c'est
faux donc il faut vraiment dissocier qui
vous êtes en tant qu'individu dans votre
travail bien sûr vous n'êtes pas une
personne différente mais vous apporter
des compétences à une entreprise qui
vont faire que forcément vous n'apportez
pas les mêmes compétences à votre
domicile je vous donne un exemple
par exemple une une comptable ne va pas
ne va pas faire ne va pas faire des
tableaux excel croisés dynamiques
à son conjoint par exemple tout comme
elle ne va pas faire la vaisselle au
boulot à part si effectivement aller
dans une thématique de harcèlement ce
qui peut malheureusement arriver donc
pour en revenir à la l'emprise dans le
couple il faut vraiment déconstruire
cette pensée je tiens vraiment vraiment
vraiment vraiment à le dire moi j'ai
beaucoup beaucoup échangé sur les
réseaux sociaux avec des femmes
majoritairement des femmes est très très
peu d'hommes je dirais malheureusement
je pense que pour les hommes c'est
encore un sujet un sujet tabou et qu'il
ne devrait plus l'être mais en tout cas
j'ai échangé avec beaucoup beaucoup de
femmes et et je me suis rendue compte
qu'elle venait tout de milieux sociaux
très différents de cultures différentes
de religion différente de couleur de
peau différente de d'âgés différents et
qu'il n'y avait absolument aucune
logique ni profil type
donc il faut vraiment être conscient que
ça peut arriver à n'importe qui par
contre il ya quelque chose de
fondamental c'est quand vous êtes
fragilisé par un événement dans votre
vie par exemple et c'est là où ou
peut-être la deuxième partie de mon
intervention va plus s'axer sur comment
s'en sortir quelque part parce que
définir l'emprise dire voilà ce qu'il en
prise
c'est bien beau mais à l'arrivée comment
on s'en sort parce que c'est possible de
s'en sortir il faut bien réaliser qu'il
ya des moments dans notre vie où nous
sommes fragilisés
ça peut être la perte d'un emploi ça
peut être un divorce ça peut être la
perte d'un proche d'un parent et c'est
toujours un événement dramatique et
c'est toujours dans ces moments là bien
souvent malheureusement que les
personnes que j'appelle toxiques
je n'aime pas le terme bourreau je
déteste ce mot que des personnes
toxiques vont entrer dans vos vies il
faut savoir qu'une personne toxiques à
la comme des petits capteurs qui vont
faire qu'elle va sentir votre fragilité
là où quelqu'un va être détruit
peut-être en quinze jours une personne
qui sera dans une fragilité moins
importante
ça mettra peut-être un an deux ans à se
produire mais le résultat sera le même
c'est à dire cette perte d'identité
encore une fois et cette perte de
confiance en soi
donc comment se sortir de l'emprise au
fond de vous chacun a la possibilité
d'avoir des petits capteurs ce que
j'appelle moi des petits capteurs
sensoriels les petites antennes
vous déployez vos petites antennes et il
ya quelque chose de très facile qui
était qui est à faire dès que vous
ressentez un malaise un mal être une
sensation de comme si vous aviez du mal
à respirer ou je ne sais pas vous vous
sentez pas comme d'habitude en tout cas
c'est que la personne qui est en face de
vous n'est probablement pas quelqu'un
qui va vouloir du bien
alors vous me direz ok ça fait un peu
chaman machin etc
pas du tout on a tous cette faculté de
pouvoir sentir l'autre une personne qui
va être bonne pour quelqu'un ne le sera
pas forcément pour vous il faut pas
juste cataloguer les gens et on sort de
l'emprise à partir du moment où on
comprend qu'on est dedans et on comprend
qu'on est dedans lorsque on ne se
reconnaît plus et on a tous la capacité
de pouvoir prendre ce recul est de
pouvoir réaliser que l'on n'est plus la
personne que l'on était et à partir de
ce moment là il ya un problème si
quelqu'un réussi à vous faire faire des
choses que jamais vous n'auriez fait il
y a un problème est là il faut
absolument mettre un terme à ce
phénomène d'emprise et malheureusement
dans une relation de couple
il s'agit de quitter l'autre et de
couper tout lien
il ne faut absolument pas conserver de
lien avec une personne toxiques parce
qu'elle restera toxiques jusqu'au bout
pour vous c'est la chose sûrement la
plus difficile à faire de couper ce lien
après il est évident qu'il faut se faire
aider
moi je suis pour le fait de se faire
aider de consulter un psychologue un
psychiatre un professionnel qui va vous
aider à comprendre
parce qu'il ya forcément une raison qui
fait que vous avez accepté que quelqu'un
d'autre n'aurait pas accepté à votre
place il ya des gens qui n'acceptent pas
et qui partent et qu'il ne se retrouve
pas souvent prise parce qu'ils
n'acceptent pas pour moi je pense qu'il
y à plusieurs facteurs
il faut apprendre à s'aimer soi même si
vous vous aimez pas vous allez attirer
des personnes toxiques à vous je dis pas
d'être prétentieux je ne dis pas d'être
imbu de sa personne je dis tout
simplement de s'aimer de s'aimer en tant
qu'individu de s'apprécier d'apprécier
son son reflet dans le miroir tout
simplement il ya des associations qui
existent
il ya des gens qui sont là pour vous
aider le problème du milieu associatif
et de tout ça c'est que moi je n'y ai
pas participé pas parce que il n'y avait
pas les compétences nécessaires pour
m'aider mais parce qu on me laissait
dans cette posture de victime
ehome infantilise est d'une certaine
manière et je n'avais pas envie d'être
infantilisés
j'avais juste besoin d'une aide à un
moment précis de ma vie j'avais besoin
qu'on m'aide à comprendre et j'avais
besoin de pouvoir avancer
et malheureusement j'ai fait des
rencontres qui m'ont laissée dans cette
posture de victime
il ne faut absolument pas à rester dans
la posture de victime
vous n'êtes pas une victime
avi vous êtes une personne entière avec
ses défauts et ses qualités comme
n'importe qui d'autre
et vous avez eu la malchance un moment
donné de rencontrer un ou une individus
sur votre parcours qui a détruit tout ça
et maintenant il faut vous reconstruire
et se reconstruire ne veut pas dire je
suis une victime
avi vous étiez quelqu'un avant de
rencontrer cette personne et vous êtes
toujours quelqu'un après être parti de
cette relation
donc je vous invite vraiment vraiment
vraiment vraiment à apprendre à vous
aimer à rencontrer un professionnel qui
vous écoute et si celui que vous
rencontrez ne vous convient pas
c'est pas grave vous en changez jusqu'à
temps que vous trouviez quelqu'un qui
vous comprennent et qu'ils vous entendre
et ne restez pas dans cette posture
victimaire elles n'apportent rien de
positif
en conclusion le point essentiel la
prise de conscience que l'une est sous
emprise quitter cette relation toxique
couper les liens et se faire aider par
un psychiatre et ne pas rester dans la
position de victime voilà je me remercie
de m'avoir écouté j'espère que tout ceci
vous aidera et je vous souhaite une
bonne conférence merci
[Musique]